that was I think something that really
frustrated me at the time like guys
don't you understand
I promise this is this is what I'm dying
to do having always been a writer first
I'm obsessed with the syncopation of the
way that words sound when they're said a
certain way I think people don't know
they want to be surprised but I think
they do want to be surprised
I get awakened by song ideas all the
time when you start to compare yourself
to other people please change the
channel in your mind to something else
she's an American singer songwriter and
actress she became the youngest woman
ever to be included in the Forbes most
powerful 100 list she's one of the
best-selling artists of all time having
sold over 40 million albums she's Taylor
Swift and here's my take on her top ten
rules for success number three is my
favorite and make sure to stick her on
all the way to the end for some special
bonus clips biggest challenge of this
year actually was convincing members of
my own team that this was a good call
I'd get kind of called in front of a
group of people who have known me and
worked with me for years who would sit
down and say are you sure you want to
call the album 1989 we think it's a
weird title are you sure that you want
to put an album cover out that has less
than half of your face on it are you
positive that you want to you want to
take a genre that you have that cemented
yourself in and completely switch to a
new one that you are a newcomer to and
answering all those questions with yes
I'm sure that was I think something that
really frustrated me at the time like
guys don't you understand I promise this
is this is what I'm dying to do the
biggest kind of struggle turned into the
biggest triumph when it worked you can
only hope that as a writer you start
trying different things and you try
different chords or different structures
of songs different beats that you've
never really explored that path before
um you know and I think having always
been a writer first I'm obsessed with
the syncopation of the way that words
sound when they're said a certain way
and
once I've kind of done something once I
always want to go to a different
direction and never repeat myself so as
a writer I think that I've always hoped
that my music would constantly be
changing because you never want to make
the same album twice the same song twice
and you know my greatest hope has been
that as I grow my fans will grow up with
me and as I change and my life changes
my music will change as well so wish me
luck there I was trying to that video
was just about dancing as badly as you
possibly can I think for me I read I
read all these comments from my fans
about how they feel embarrassed all the
time they're just really left out lonely
and so I guess I just wanted to make a
music video that was just sort of like
sort of embarrassing and sort of like
just not cool like not being cool at all
not trying to be because I wanted you
know I can tech I can tell them all I
want be yourself
it doesn't matter if people think you're
sexy or edgy or cool but if I don't lead
by example then I am not actually
conveying that message fully so with
this video like it's not a sexy video
but it conveys a message I really want
to get across to girls that like if
that's not your thing you don't have to
try to be like everyone else the only
time in the last couple of years that I
knew as soon as we finished a song that
it was sort of a like I hate to say the
GameChanger
but it was sort of a next-level
situation was when I finished shake it
off and but I wanted me I wanted to be
sure so I that was the very end of the
recording process
I finished shake it off and I knew I was
done with the record and I flew back to
Nashville had a bunch of label people
who I trust and a bunch of management
who I trust and my mom and dad sit in my
parents living room and I played them
the full record and I didn't tell them
anything about how I thought I had
written the first single I didn't tell
them anything like you gotta listen like
listen for track eight shake it off is
the one I'm telling you but when that
song came on and halfway through all of
them look at me and go this is the one
it was such a Val
dating feeling because I thought I knew
I was so sure I knew and then it turned
out I did know that about how you wrote
a novel when you're 11 years old I was
four or teen no wait you were younger I
was like 13 I think Jean yeah but I did
I was um I was I have a lot of different
epiphanies I'm always have different
ideas as to like oh you know this would
be a good idea and one summer I was I
was at the shore we used to spend our
summers in Stone Harbor New Jersey and
all my friends were back in Pennsylvania
and so I had nothing to do and so I had
this epiphany I'm going to be a novelist
and I'm going to write novels and that's
going to be my career path and so I
would write different chapters of this
book and send them back to my friends
and I'd write them into the kit into the
book under different names but totally
describe their personalities and it was
a really fun way to spend the summer and
my parents were so frustrated because I
would never go outside I just be like
locked in this little study with my
computer but I've always been a writer
first it's it's my favorite thing is how
you can convey a thought or a story or
completely distraught describe a
character or a situation through words
and the right combination of words and
the whole process of editing and re
editing and rethinking and imagining and
you get these little mini just epiphany
ideas that come to you and I think that
that's what I loved about writing the
novel and that's what I love about
poetry and it's what I love about
songwriting I've always been really
influenced by lots of different things
musically and I've tried to stay really
open to that because I think that you
know when you're making your fifth album
you can make things this the way you've
always made them and that's fine and
it'll work and that'll do but it's not
the same as if you continue to surprise
people I think that I think people don't
know they want to be surprised but I
think they do want to be surprised
I never I never understood it when
people would say oh you know in your 20s
you just need to be alone and I just I
never quite got it because they would
never explain
to me that it's so important to define
yourself on your own terms you think
about it when you're in love that
person's opinion affects your opinions
and everything you do goes through this
filter of how would they feel about it
because if you're a caring person and
you're in love then that's what you do
but there's something really wonderful
about changing your life if you want to
cutting your hair short if you want to
move into New York if you want to
changing directions of your entire
creative outlook if you want to and
having it only be on your own terms
I try to stay pretty open to inspiration
every single day all day and if I come
up with if I come up with some line that
I feel that I feel like sounds like it
should be a highlighted line or it
sounds like it's an interesting
observation I'll write it down and this
this kind of note pad that I have in my
phone and when it comes time to finish a
song I'll just go through all the lines
and look at them and go okay this works
for this this works for that mmm it's
really fun it's it's it's fun to
continue to stay open to inspiration all
the time and always be looking is it do
you have like any sort of favorite place
for writing songs no actually I kind of
have become you have to adapt yourself
to a million different places to write
when you're always on the road because I
just I don't have the luxury of saying
well I have to be in this certain room
at this certain part of town and it has
to be you know all one color tone and
there has to be smart water in there you
know like it's just you're never ever
anywhere from more than two and a half
seconds so you know I've written songs
in Airport bathrooms on paper towels
I've written songs which what song was
on a on a bathroom towel at one point oh
it hasn't come out yet Oh
um you know in the bus bunk you'll wake
up in the middle of the night and you'll
have this idea and then so you write it
and you're up at 4:00 a.m. or you know I
get awakened by song ideas all the time
and it's just it's like I wake up and
I'm just like oh great because I know I
won't forget I won't remember it in the
morning so you have to record it and
then it's this whole thing where you
check your phone and it's like mumbling
and you don't understand I'm when you
start to compare yourself to other
people please change the channel in your
mind to something else because
I think that when it comes to how we see
ourselves other people are really mean
the world really mean to ourselves
so it's easy to get confused and when
you do get confused and you start
feeling like you're not special or
you're not different or you have nothing
important to say we all feel like that
sometimes but I want you to do right now
for one thing you remember from tonight
remember what I'm about to say you need
to look into the mirror in the morning
and not tell yourself that you're not
special you're not gonna know you're not
tell you right now the things you
actually are not okay these are the
things you really are not you are not
the opinion of somebody who doesn't know
you
you are not damaged goods just because
you've made mistakes in your life you
are not going nowhere just because you
haven't gotten where you want to go yet
those are the things you actually are
not now I want to tell you what you are
you are your own definition of beautiful
and worth entity and you are someone who
is wiser because you hate mistakes is
not damaged wiser
you are somebody who could be at this
moment right now sitting there there
there there there there there you are
going through whatever you're going
through in your life that's stressing
you out and confusing you are making you
upset but you got a bed and you put on
an awesome outfit and
no it's all our perfection it's it's
about just getting on with things
sometimes sometimes you just get credit
for getting up and going on with things
you don't do it perfectly and I think
that we must see our mistakes for damage
and you think other people will judge us
for them but I want you to know that the
way I see mistakes they don't make you
damaged it made you clean
thank you so much for watching I made
this video because see any ask me too so
there's a famous entrepreneur that you
want me to profile next leave it in the
comments below and I'll see what I can
do I also love to know what your Taylor
Swift's top 10 rules have the biggest
impact on you and why leave in the
comments below and I will join in the
discussion finally I want to give a
quick shadow to kuljeet Dahlia for
ordering my book thank you so much I
really appreciate it to get your chains
at a shadow in a future video make sure
you email in the receipts
after you pre-order the book thank you
guys so much for watching continue to
believe or whatever your one word is and
I'll see you soon
why were to give advice to a girl or a
woman wanting to get into the music
industry I think the first thing I would
tell them is that you know you're going
to have thousands of decisions to make
on a daily basis that will end up
depicting your image your sound all the
things that will shape the public's
perception of you as an artist
let those decisions be your decisions
don't let them be some man in a suits
decisions or some ANR guy wearing a
beanie whether it's what you decide to
wear how you feel confident onstage what
you want your persona to be what you
want to stand for what you're going to
stand up for and most of all creatively
I think you should steer the ship and
you have something else as I'm told I
had no idea what they're talking about
Oh Zack wanted to show you how he
learned how to play guitar I taught him
to play guitar yeah I got my first
guitar lesson from Taylor he's really
good at it for like one lesson it's
really great one lesson he had like one
lesson he's good at a meet and we
learned I taught him how to play Pumped
Up Kicks by Foster the People
really yes yeah all right G are you
gonna play guitar uh kidding there's two
guitars coming out
so yeah you can use my guitar I'll use
your cool you have your own picks Taylor
sweet I know that's all I can do is put
picks guitar but yeah this is my face
that's interested in awkward but um that
you don't show her the chords that you
know okay let's see what's first one
yeah uh a minor hair and lair
alright here we go mm-hmm sounds so good
only in your home would react that
quickly like that to DDD than any major
there it is
all right so you go like yeah yeah
that's great turkey
take it better
faster than my bullet you change the
lyrics if you want to like see what I
come up with Harvey yeah
Ellen works a long day
if it weird interviews in a slick cool
sweater and
it's kind of weird yeah calling us and
like we're boyfriend and girlfriend but
it's not just what you sitting here and
we got cat videos and different Betty
White and stuff and Kim's always gonna
mean weird the song is all about Ellen
every time on this show it's really
weird
it's really
and an answer
the bathroom
he died
I was asking who I'm dating every time
I don't even know why
music
every single
screaming
always and imagine
Wow